all right guys
bang bang i have mr michael saylor here
uh you're an absolute legend my friend
uh thank you so much for uh for doing
this
happy to be here uh let's start
uh you are bitcoin famous now uh for
being the ceo of
the first publicly traded company to
convert a material amount of your
balance sheet into bitcoin and use it as
a reserve asset
we will get to all of that fun stuff in
a minute but let's just start with your
background
and kind of how you got to running micro
strategy what that business does
and kind of that background that really
led you to this
okay i grew up in an air force family
lived on military bases my entire life
i went to mit on an air force
scholarship
i i got a degree in astronautical
engineering
studied spaceship design while i was
there i got another degree in the
history of science i studied the
structure of scientific revolutions and
paradigm shifts
and became very fascinated with how new
new technologies get
introduced um learned to fly in the air
force
uh but i never went active duty because
just as i was about to graduate
the cold war ended the reagan
star wars buildup won it and uh
one day my commanding officer walked
into the room and said you know we paid
for education you're on the hook for
five years
active duty but if you want to join the
reserve you can do that
if you want to go active duty then
you're gonna wait two years before you
get called up
so you know the choice would get paid
three times as much in the civilian
world
or you know and serve in the reserve or
um wait so um
this was an easier choice for me because
i was going to be a pilot and
in my final semester i was diagnosed
mistakenly with the benign heart murmur
and it disqualified me from flying
combat jets
and so my hopes dash to being a fighter
pilot
uh i decided i did not uh want to wait
around
and so i joined the air force reserve
and uh i became a civilian
unexpectedly uh in the final month
of my undergraduate career um i thought
i wanted to be a professor
i got into into a phd program but i had
no money
and so i decided i would go work for a
year
and then i would apply for a fellowship
and then i would go back and
and uh get my phd um
i worked for the first six months the
company i worked for blew up
you know and i ended up working at
dupont and i was building computer
simulations for dupont
and uh around the 18-month point i
attended my resignation to go back to
mit
and uh i was building computer
simulations to predict uh
the return on billion dollar capital
investments in the petrochemical
industry
and the computer model is going to be
used to justify a 1.5
billion dollar investment and the
executive that wanted the money
you know i'm sure he said to his
staffers hey tell the kid we need him to
finish the job
and i was 24 and
living in an apartment with milk crates
for bookshelves spending 700 bucks a
month
and i knew i didn't want to stay and be
a corporate bureaucrat so i was like no
i'm not staying and the
the executive said well give whatever he
wants and i said well you want to raise
i was like no i don't want to race it
well what do you want to say well when i
was in high school i wanted to be a
rock and roll star and that was dash and
when i was in college i wanted to be a
fighter pilot astronaut and those hopes
were dashed and my third idea was be a
professor
and that's what i'm going to go do and
there's only one last thing on my
checklist which is i'd like to be a ceo
of my own company
and i said okay so if you want me to
stay
you're gonna have to let me start my
company i want i think i got a quarter
million dollars in cash two and a half
million dollars a contract so let me
hire ten people from dupont
give me free off the space and computer
equipment for the first two or three
years
i took the you know they said we can't
give you the money up front you're just
a 24 year old i said
you got to because this is the only time
this negotiating strategy ever works i
said
you got to give me the money because i
have no money
like i had um you know they said well
but and they went back to their boss and
they did this deal that you would never
ever ever do but i just happened to be
the one guy on the east coast that could
make their computer program work
and the guy was 12 weeks from getting a
billion dollar
check from a mega corporation and it was
all irrelevant so
they gave me the money i i thought
holy crap i have 250 000 this is enough
capital to last me for seven years
so i figured seven years good let's
start
and so age 24 i started microstrategy
with the thought that
i didn't want to work for anybody else
and when it failed
i would go back to college and uh it
never failed in the first year we did
you know
10 people and then 20 and then we were 5
million then we were 10 million then we
were 20 million then we were 40 million
and at some point we were 80 million and
then we kind of came to the market and
uh you know
96 97 time frame and the dot com
revolution revolution's going crazy
everybody's clamoring you got to go
public so we came public in 1998
and uh then there was no going back you
know i got on the roller coaster
and uh so that's how i started
microstrategy i didn't
i didn't mean to i kind of fell off the
turnip truck
and hit my head on a pot of gold and
i'll keep it
so when you decided to go public uh this
was like right in the heart
or at the start really of like kind of
this mania phase
talk a little bit about um going through
as a public company
uh leader kind of the multiple market
cycles right because
if you went public in 98 you get 99 this
big boom you have to get the crash
you kind of then see you know another
rise 0809 happens right then you kind of
get this
incredible uh decade in the equity
markets um and then you get covid
it's like how have you kind of navigated
every single one of these because i
don't think a lot of people realize like
you started coming at 24 years old
you're still running that company today
right and so it's been a journey you
know like
i i here's an irony you know i never got
that phd
i'm just like a silly mit undergraduate
i remember i was competing in my early
years with this guy
this professor from mit who had like
umpteen degrees and was so much more
educated and you know i would be running
a million dollar company he's got a
million dollar company and he said what
are you doing i said
well i'm building these computer
simulations on a macintosh he said
you know well all the experts say the
macintosh is going to die that's a bad
idea
so well eventually i you know eventually
i ported it to windows and
the next time i saw him the company's
five million dollars and we're working
on windows and he goes
what are you doing i said well i'm
building i'm building executive
information systems on windows machines
using this thing called wings this new
spreadsheet with a programming language
he said oh well experts say that wings
will never work
excel's going to dominate the
spreadsheet market and that's about idea
he was still running the million dollar
consulting company giving advice
i said okay well it turns out he was
right and in a year we flipped the
company and we rebuilt the product
on visual basic and we doubled again and
he said what are you doing i said well
now we're doing this like executive
information
decision support system and he goes well
that you know that won't work on visual
basic you're gonna use c plus plus
and and he stayed 1 million and we were
like 20 million
and then the next thing you know we uh
started building decision support
systems on relational databases and
everything
well that'll never work that's too slow
right and
and it kind of worked until we got to 40
million and then along came the web and
we flipped it again we put a web
interface on it and that got us to 80
million
and and every single two or three years
there's something new
that was simultaneously an existential
threat
like it's gonna kill us or an
opportunity
if we embrace it and we're always
inventing the next
thing so eventually we found ourselves
into the business intelligence business
and
and we created business intelligence web
intelligence relational intelligence and
uh i had three big competitors there
business objects cognos you know crystal
reports
and uh we got to like 2007 2008
and conventional wisdom-wise well they
all had to sell out so all three of them
sold one sold oracle one sold sap one
sold
ibm and we were still standing
right and then we accrued so some more
some more customers and we kept
motoring on and then along came the
iphone
you know and the iphone the first iphone
in 2007 was kind of a toy
had no cut and paste no app store 2009
the iphone actually started looking
pretty interesting and and i just i
became very enamored
with with the mobile wave this uh what
happens when software
leaps off of a pc out from under your
desk because that's what they were i
mean the computers were
rocks under your desk and they were ugly
and they had lots of cables coming out
of them i thought
what if the software is running in your
hand and what if that phone's in your
pocket
it's like software going from solid
state block of ice
it gets the liquid a laptop and then it
goes to vapor state and a vapor state
was on the phone
and i thought well man that all of a
sudden instead of going to the office to
sit down at a desk and run your software
maybe you have the software your kids
soccer game on a saturday afternoon
and then maybe rethink how the software
works
so we we started uh doing mobile stuff
and we implemented mobile intelligence
and uh
that took us to the next level now along
the way i kind of
i i took one path but i was always kind
of um
a tech inventor at heart entrepreneur
so back in uh 96 when the internet hit
you needed an email domain so we bought
microstrategy.com
but i was too lazy so i thought why do i
gonna type microstrategy.com why don't
we buy strategy.com
so we went we bought back with no one
care we bought strategy.com for like
50 grand and then i and then i thought
why don't we just start buying words so
we bought wisdom.com
and then we bought usher.com and by the
way
do you know who owns hope in the world
no
i own hope hope.com hope
emma i bought speaker i bought alert
i bought angel i bought alarm
i bought voice i mean and and here's my
thinking
you know there are all these search
engines and if you go
online and you search for voice you get
like 2 billion hits on google
okay if you want to launch a company
name voice and you own voice.com
you go to the top of the list of the
billion
and so my thinking was
if 10 billion 5 billion people go to
school and they learn how to spell
alert or emma right emma
e-m-m-h if they know how to spell that
isn't that good for a brand and so i
started thinking about branding and
and uh i launched a business alarm.com
we eventually spun it off it's a
multi-billion dollar publicly traded
company on the nasdaq today
uh and uh yeah we made some money
we didn't make the billions but we made
a lot of money off of it like 30 40
million
and then we launched another company
about an alarm was all about
integrating your home alarm system with
the internet
yeah and then we launched another
company called angel
and angel was like an early version of
siri it was an interactive voice
response from any telephone
like an angel on your shoulder talk to
it and they respond
we eventually sold that for about 100
120 million
and so you know what i learned was
it's easier to invent things and and
it's easier you know you can
invent something you can even get it to
scale um
can you can you maintain it and can you
commercialize it
right a lot of people find like you can
buy that boat
can you afford to maintain that boat
that's harder now you maintain that boat
are you really going to enjoy that boat
are you going to use that thing
that's harder the analogy in business is
just because you can buy it doesn't mean
you can
uh make it competitive
and even if it's competitive doesn't
mean you can make profit from it
so eventually i learned that you can't
keep inventing stuff and
we streamlined we sold those off but i
got i got to
2020 in 2019
where i sold voice.com i tell you that
story in a bit but i got to 2020 and we
had a portfolio domain names are sitting
there
i appreciated digital scarcity i thought
these are unique in the universe only
one person can own the work by the way
you know who owns michael.com
please tell me it's you yeah by the way
and and you know who's lazy i thought
what if someone just wants to type in
mike about that too
i'm waiting for michael jordan to call
me up
why wouldn't you own michael.com how
much money do you think you spent on
domains over the years acquiring all of
these
two million bucks million bucks okay so
so
let's call it low single-digit seven
figures right so a million two million
three million whatever it is
back in the back in the day back in the
90s and i just sat on them because i
figured
the english language is going to be
around for a while okay
and before you sold voice.com how much
do you think that you had made from
selling the domains
we made like 35 million
in the alarm transaction and more than
100 million in the angel transaction so
so but we had we had uh commercialized
businesses with them so we sold the
domain
and and the business with them as part
of it and uh
voice was the first uh the first naked
domain
sale that we did that was material
and we did that one for 30 million and
we just sold the domain nothing else
and when you go to do this uh
when people hear wait a second the same
guy who did this bitcoin thing
sold a domain for 30 million dollars uh
he also has a business that's worth you
know over a billion dollars in the
public markets etc
uh he's spun off multiple companies that
are now worth
tens of millions hundreds of millions of
dollars like this guy just keeps
hits after hit after hit after hit uh
how does something like voice.com come
together do they approach you
do you put it up on like a broker site
and say hey there's a 30 million dollar
domain
how does that work you know at some
point i i said to my marketing people
why don't you make a list of all of our
premium domains
and my definition of a premium domain is
is a domain where if you hit the google
search you will get 500 million hits or
a billion or
five billion hits when you typed it in
the search engine
and they're all just you know ideas like
wisdom and hope
yeah and uh i said why don't you make a
list of them and send them out to every
you know everybody we know
and see if he's interested in them and
we sent out the letter
and we heard back you know nothing right
maybe i got like two
venture capitalists called me but
nothing ever went anywhere and i was
like okay
forget that go back running my own
business
and with voice you know this is how this
goes down
i'm sitting at my desk one day and uh
one of my junior
20-something business development reps
walks and he goes hey some broker
you know called us and and they offered
us like a hundred and fifty thousand
dollars
you know for uh this domain voice
and i looked at it and i'm like look
i've been waiting for 20
stinking years like 150
000 isn't going to do much for me i said
tell them no
okay so nothing nothing goes on and then
they come back
they uh they offered us 300 000 now i
said
well tell them no don't bother me so i
waited
and then the next day they come back and
they doubled at six hundred thousand
i said uh nope still not interested
um tell them tell them it's gonna have
to be
something north of you know 10 million
bucks i'm just not interested
they go well they they offered 1.2
and then it went to 3 and then it went
to 6.
and when it got to 10 or something like
that
finally that you know i'm starting i've
got all these
other people lobbying me sales people
sitting like
jackals you know like you're going to
want to
you know they're all like you have to
sell this you have to sell this
and this is where we're selling
selling intangible assets like anything
artwork
it all comes down to how much are they
worth to you
right and so if you needed the 10
million dollars
you would have taken the 10 million
dollars but
at this point you know i have 500
million dollars of cash in the bank
if i and and by i i love my things you
know like
i i love them tears right maybe you can
tell that i'm a little bit
passionate about some of this stuff you
know so
i would rather own it and not have the
10 million
then sell it you know for for that so i
said don't know
they say okay well they went up to 22
million
i said i think when they said 10 i said
the numbers
i'll sell it for 30 million so the only
price i ever put on the table
30 million bucks i didn't like nothing
else i was like
after i get to 10 i'm like i will sell
it for 30 million because that's enough
to i thought by like it's i didn't sell
for 30 million because i thought that's
what it was worth
i think that the word voice in the
english language is worth 100 million
like i've seen people drop a hundred
million dollars on an ad campaign and
you want to drop a hundred million an ad
campaign with the with the i
voice dot net type domain
it's like so i thought it was worth more
but i thought well like i
i need to market to market i need to
like create some kind of market comp for
it so we'll do 30 million so i tell them
39
they said they'll give you 22. i said
uh no but tell them i'll talk to them
and so around 22 million i agreed to get
on the phone
and you know so like i'm talking to a
broker
and a lawyer i'm like i you know all
through this we're like well who's the
buyer who's the buyer
not some some somebody you know like
and if they'd said if someone has said
yeah we're a startup and we've got like
12 million dollars in the bank and we'll
give you all of our cash and this is all
we've got
maybe they might have swayed me but
but i just had a whale on the other end
of the line that
that wouldn't identify themselves and i
thought
okay well that's the case i'm just gonna
wait until they hit my bid you know if
you had
if you had an acre in central park and
someone wanted to buy it from you
and the price is the price you would
wait and then once
it's like you don't want it i'll wait i
got another decade
i'm not going anywhere somebody's going
to eventually want to commercialize
voice
so eventually they got on the phone and
i'm talking to a broker but i hear like
a click click and there's other people
eavesdropping on the line so
i'm kind of just talking to myself they
said well we're authorized to go to 22
or 23 million i said you know i'm sorry
i said
go to the google search engine and type
in voice right now
and then why don't you what you'll
notice is that it's more popular than
like what's up
with a billion users it's a better brand
than you would get you know
if you were to um get a billion people
online it's it's a better brand than
than oracle or then sap or the hundred
billion dollar plus companies
so this is how i value it i'm
i said like this is like my daughter
i'll marry her off
but only to a man that's going to treat
her better than i will treat her
so if you guys really value this then
give me the 30 million otherwise i'm
keeping it
you know and and so at some point they
come up to 30 million
right you guys agree to 30 million
but did you know who it was before you
agreed
no i never knew who it was
really okay so you agree i sold it in
the blind
basically saying no from 150 grand up to
30 million
and then finally they did it i still
didn't know who it was until after
the transaction closed and then i hear
it's some crypto company and that's the
end of it for me
and that's my introduction to crypto i i
literally
am thinking about the broker who's like
okay just showing up to work 150 000
trying to buy a domain and next thing
they know a couple weeks later they're
brokering 30 million
deals and probably you know they're
peeing in their pants right trying just
hoping to god this goes through because
they're already thinking about what
house they're going to buy based on the
commission type situation right
it was amusing
and so you do this you say that it's
your first
uh kind of foray or experience with
crypto
but there's no experience with crypto
all right so there's this tweet
there's this tweet that everyone is
begging me to talk to you about
which is in uh i think it's 2012 or
2013.
you basically put out a tweet so you're
early because it's 2012 2013 about
bitcoin
uh you're also on twitter then which was
still pretty early for uh for twitter in
general
uh and you basically tweet out you know
kind of saying what i would consider a
pretty
uh down the fairway critique of bitcoin
which is like it's not going anywhere
yeah right fast forward seven online
gambling it's days or another
yeah seven eight years and uh now you've
got a material part of your balance
sheet
in bitcoin what happens how does that
happen okay anthony
can i tell you the truth of course i
i got an iphone back in the day
i installed twitter on it and it used to
be really fun and i used to really enjoy
reading the news and tweeting stuff
right it's like it was like you know by
the way there are certain people on
twitter
that still seem to enjoy just tweeting
out whatever the heck they want
so i was in that stage and i had a lot
of opinions
and so i'm tweeting stuff and eventually
yeah and by the way i tweeted a thousand
things i forgot all the things i tweeted
so eventually i realized that it's
probably better for
my my communication effectiveness if i
limit my
tweeting to stay on brand so
like i have a company micro strategy if
i have something intelligent to say
about microstrategy i say it
and i have a non-profit foundation the
sailor academy that gives away free
education to hundreds of thousands of
people we're just giving away a free
college degree
and if i have something that i can do to
help them i say it
and then whenever anybody else does
anything that i might have an opinion
i keep my mouth shut now because i've
realized
it's just an opinion and i've lived long
enough to be wrong on a lot of things
but now coming back to that specific
tweet
i i really am ashamed to say i didn't
know i tweeted it until
the day that i tweeted that i bought 250
million worth of bitcoin
and then i discovered the hive mind
crypto twitter consciousness where all
of a sudden
they all went through all my tweets they
found it
they reminded me of it they compared it
and i'm like oh my god i
literally forgot i ever said that
and you know but i i took it as kind of
like kind
ribbing like i didn't get all worked up
about i'm like you're right
i was wrong what an idiot i was
i wish i could go back and do it again
well the part to me that was uh so funny
about all this is one you're right that
uh the internet never forgets
right and it sounds like you were using
twitter early on how i use it which is
sometimes i literally tweet things and i
tweet them for myself to remember
what i'm thinking right like i just you
know throw something out there
uh the problem is that uh the internet
doesn't forget and even if that was a
thought in the moment right you change
your mind later it's a stamp
you know kind of uh that never goes away
and
uh so when they found it and i saw that
i was like oh my god this is amazing
like
literally in a six seven year time
period it's not just from uh
i don't believe it has value to oh maybe
it has some value right i mean you
would you consider the move uh
of taking the 250 million the first
investment
is that a bet the company type move
or do you look at that as more uh
conservative than
a bet the company type decision i i
wouldn't say
i would not say it's a bet the company
decision
um what i would say is
we looked at it and before i made that
that uh decision before the before i was
able to convince anybody on the board or
the executive team to agree that was the
right idea
we all needed to collectively be of the
opinion that we were going to be
generating cash at
infinitum right so
so uh like there's a journey that we
went through corporately
over the past year and there's a journey
that bitcoin went through over the last
seven years
so if we focus upon our journey
we had 500 600 million in cash
and we were buying our stock back a bit
and then we were thinking maybe we'll
need to buy another company we need it
for a rainy day or maybe something
really bad will happen
and we'll really need the money and you
know one of my heroes is steve jobs
and steve jobs you know you know if you
had a near bankruptcy experience and he
did
and i did too by the way by the way i i
lived uh
i lived to see my stock go from 333
dollars a share to 42 cents
okay wait wait wait wait hold on back up
yeah the stock price fell what what
time period is this you know it's not
like i like to brag about this stuff
because it's not something you want to
be proud of
but i will tell you that that two of my
bragging rights are
i am the pretty much the longest lived
public company ceo
in my industry because i've been public
company ceo for 22 years
and the second thing is is i'm pretty
sure i'm the only public company ceo
that ever presided over a 99.8
drop in the stock price and kept his job
i mean this okay so when does this
happen like what is 2003
you know okay i i look it's it's another
story i learned a lot of lessons
at the short we don't want to get off
the subject of bitcoin the subject of
whatever
the short the the short lesson there is
don't run out of money always have cash
on the ballot sheet and don't spend more
money
than you're taking in and i feel like an
idiot to give that advice to anybody
but it's still good advice right now for
sure let's come let's fast forward
back to 2020. um
so we had the money we're
we are very conservative no debt ready
for a rainy day
ready to seize the opportunity buying a
stock back
covet hits the pandemic hits everybody's
you know our equities in the tank you
know
uh we're losing momentum and the first
thing that happens in in
q1 is it's all kind of shock and awe and
in q2
the question is how does this impact my
customers our business
our product our value proposition
and uh you know and by the way everybody
gets impacted differently right if
you're running a cruise line or a
theater or
whatever and sometimes
counter-intuitively and uh
in our case we sell enterprise software
that helps you think better we sell
business intelligence
and we sell business intelligence to to
lots of governments
agencies we sell it to massive banks we
sell it to
in essence global 2000 companies
even the ones that get impacted they're
like the national airline
they can't go out of business right they
so
that's our customer base so we realized
that
our software kept working demand was
still there
everything is smooth and in fact the
great thing about software is software
you can ship
even you know over the internet all of
our services went remote
so our value proposition's intact and
the the surprise for us is our
is our productivity went through the
roof and our cost structure compressed
all of a sudden you know 20 million
dollars a year flying around in
airplanes
went away and 10 million dollars worth
of trade shows and
20 million dollars worth of marketing
things went away
but the customer in the band didn't go
away so we we actually
found that we were much more efficient
so bottom line
is yeah we got that black swan event
but that block swan event actually
kicked us into a high gear
productivity and so that was the that
was the positive
on the on the p l side we uh we realized
that we were going to generate more cash
and we and there and there was no real
no real rational business plan where i
take 200 million dollars and i spend it
to make the business better
i can burn it to make the bit but i
can't spend it to make the business
better
so simultaneously
we got a gift from the fed and the
macroeconomic side
so while we're trying to figure out what
happens on on the p
l all of a sudden we see
what do we see the long bond index goes
up 22
if you would ask me anthony like what's
the
what's the investment that you do not
want to make i would never
in a million years buy a 30-year bond
that yielded two percent interest
never ever and yet that was a winner
this year
if you bought a 30-year bond at 2
interest when the interest rates go
to 1.2 you've actually got a massive
spike so equity spiked big tech spiked
bond spiked and you know and we looked
at our cash and i had to listen to a
litany of of talking heads
ray dalio on doubt you know if ray dalio
didn't say
cash is trash every podcaster that
trolled ray dalio
said ray dalio says cash is trash cash
is trash
and you know and then i and then i went
to school at some point on you this is
probably
this is after i realized i had a problem
and and i listened to you describe the
plight of the working man i
you know i go to work i get paid
five i'm okay this is not a work man
this is a working lawyer
i get paid five hundred thousand dollars
a year i save fifty thousand dollars i
put it in my piggy bank i have five
hundred thousand in cash in the bank i
have kids and i have a future
and then all of a sudden i realize that
the cost of a college education
is going up at eight percent a year and
my cash is yielding
zero now at that point you know we've
got
the pomp podcast telling me i'm crazy
to work for dollars and save my cash
and if you take the five hundred
thousand dollars in the plight of the
lawyer with the two kids when i send
them to harvard and the 500
000 of cash in the bank yielding zero
and now you multiply everything by a
thousand
that's me i have 500 million dollar
company
we're making 50 million dollars a year i
got thousands of people working as hard
as they can possibly work
we're we're sacrificing right and left
we're squirring our pennies away we're
putting it into the bank account
there it is and uh you know in 2019 and
before
we worried about the unknowable and we
thought maybe we'll use it for something
and
i i'm a bit older than you you know i
remember when you got five percent
interest overnight on your money
and it wasn't that long ago that the
risk-free interest rate was five percent
before the great financial crisis
and i'm like i'm gonna make 25 30
million dollars a year on this
and i kept hoping and waiting for those
good times to come back
i was the guy that when the interest
rates you know when the when the 30-year
t
bill ensure you start to go to three and
a half percent like finally they're
gonna go to four
and then go to five and they're gonna go
back to normal right
normal interest rates and then of course
hope was dashed it went the other way
and um what happens next well
acid inflation goes through the roof
right and you know this entire
conversation of inflation
it's really twisted because everybody
talks about consumer prices cpi
cpi inflation that we're not getting
enough inflation
we're not getting enough inflation okay
well like
you're not getting in you're not getting
inflation on youtube
and netflix streaming videos and candy
bars manufactured by robots and
factories and domino's pizza
you're getting inflation on everything
you want
if you wanted an ivy league education if
you wanted a beachfront house in miami
if you wanted the apartment in new york
if you wanted
anything scarce everything you want
is going up seven percent and that's
asset inflation
well if if i want if i want
a bond that's going to yield fifty
thousand dollars a year
you know it used to cost a million bucks
and this year it cost 10 million dollars
the cost of the asset good went up by
two percent no i have um
i have a house in miami beach it was a
nice house built in the 1930s and i and
i have the deed
that of sale for the house a hundred
thousand dollars
for that house in 1930
it's gone up in price by a factor of a
hundred
is like you know so no inflation kind of
inflation
but it's diff it's acid inflation so i
didn't really think about it until
i got slugged in the face with the 2x4
which kind of happened around march or
april
when main street shut down the economy
shut down
and bonds went through the roof when
municipal pawns went
up while every city is bankrupt when
every
when apple stock and every other public
tech equity went
up why and the multiples blew out
and the economy went to the worst place
i've seen in 30 years
at that point you start having a thought
with yourself which is
what is what is the true inflation rate
and and
we should probably coin a different term
right if you if you looked at
asset inflation on a good year for the
last decade it's seven
percent a year normal right this year
you could make an argument it was 25
i mean if you look at the long bond
index and if you look at these equities
you can make an argument that the asset
inflation rate leaked between 25 and 30
depending and uh and now
what does that mean to me metaphorically
well here's how i feel
i felt like i had 500 million dollars of
cash
in the bank safe and it was yielding two
three percent and i'm ready for a rainy
day and then i'm starting to do stuff
with it
and then every month some banker sends
me a note saying the interest went down
it went down
now there is no interest
and then someone took my cash out of the
bank and they put it in the backyard in
pallets and then they open my back gate
and then every month someone comes along
and starts
burning two percent of the money
and then i started thinking well you
know in 12 months 25
of the money's going to be gone
and then you know then i started
thinking what is the point
of all this what am i doing wrong and of
course the answer is
you can't hold cash and so what do you
do with it
right well i mean okay so so hold on a
second here so
you realize the macro issues um
i think there was a couple of different
things that happened right so the macro
issues happen you're sitting there
you're in a very unique situation
because you have so much cash on the
company's balance sheet
um you run a business that throws off a
lot of cash right so you kind of have
that advantage
it actually improves economically like
you described in terms of your costs are
going down
that the structure of your contracts
kind of are weathering
uh very well through this storm and so
you you remain in a strong
business position where you have cash
and actually the cash is growing
not through investment it's growing from
kind of your your income
uh and you begin to get worried about
that how do you get to
crypto right and i'm leaving you a
little bit in terms of uh you've got a
friend
who basically kind of hits you over the
head a second time so let me tell that
story
as to kind of what pushes you to at
least go explore crypto
and then we can talk about kind of what
you do but just talk through that
process of like how you actually
arrive at okay crypto is a potential
solution
you know when times are good everybody's
busy
you know if you're in love with the
iphone then the answer to everything is
iphone if you're in love with your apple
watch when you're in love with twitter
the answer is
you know that you know um so when times
are good everybody focuses on that and
there's only limited time so
i i think i was closed to the
possibility it's just there's so many
other things going on
and um when uh the covid crisis hit
everybody got sent home and we all had
to
had to contemplate ideas that we had
previously rejected
and we had to embrace ideas that that
just were very foreign to us so how do i
discover crypto
well first i have a mega mega mega
problem
and the mega problem is i have a lot of
cash
and i'm watching it melt away
and i and and i'm i'm helped to realize
i have a mega problem
by this insane v recovery in
the bond market and the equity market
and uh
you know all of the talking heads so
after
after that then i have an opportunity
which is i've got a cash generating
business
and then i've got one more problem which
is the investors the at the outside
investment community if you go to them
and say
hey we're a great enterprise software
company and we've got all this cash
their answer is well we don't really
value the cash
what i mean because they're smarter than
i am right
now i'm not being i'm not joking i'm
being serious they are smarter than them
they knew before i knew that cash is
trash
and you're a fool to sit on the cash
you're just
if the natural asset inflation rate is
10
it means that every time i generate 50
million in operating income
i burn 50 million in purchasing power on
the cash
and we're just running as hard as we can
stand still
so we weren't getting any credit for the
cash
we didn't need the cash ergo we need to
do something
and so what is the thing you're gonna do
when we started
working through it like what do you do
if you have 500 million dollars of cash
you don't need why you can buy your own
stock back
right there's a limit to how fast you
can do it if you go into a market in a
thinly traded stock and you're buying 20
of the float every day you know
that's going to take about four years
right it's like you know if if your
account if your ice cube is melting
15 or 20 percent a year you don't got
four years or at least
you know inflation is going to do a
better job so that didn't really make
sense so we had
we got kicked into high gear like
everybody got kicked into high gear this
year right
if you didn't know how to use zoom you
know like we started we started uh
on a monday morning with one video
conferencing technology we discarded it
i'm not going to say which one
we discarded it for another one by 11
a.m
by 2 p.m we're using zoom by 4 p.m the
ceo sends out an edict zoom is now the
corporate standard
everyone will switch over to zoom
starting tomorrow
right that's how and by the way the same
ceo that said
i don't believe in remote work you got
to show up to the office or else you're
not working for me
and i would have sworn up and down i
hated remote work
until coveted crisis hit flip and so
that that same idea happened with the
balance sheet
they're all these strongly held views
you've got to be conservative you've got
to invest in cash and short-term t-bills
and you don't contemplate anything else
and then all of a sudden
you contemplate other things so i mean
you're an expert
you tell me if you had 500 million
dollars of cash right now
where would you invest it uh i'm
cheating because you and i see eye to
eye now cause i'd go buy a lot of
bitcoin
okay and so if you didn't know what you
know
but you were an intelligent person and
you watched youtube and you watched
everything else
what would be your laundry list of
assets to consider
investing in yeah it would basically be
all the inflation hedge assets right you
look at everything from real estate
precious metals
uh bitcoin you kind of just go down the
line hard assets that have some sort of
inflation hedge
type qualities uh that really are more
kind of wealth preservation than
anything would be the
the general bucket to at least go start
exploring with right okay so let's take
through them
commercial real estate how do you go buy
500 million dollars worth of commercial
real estate at a fair
price that's not an impaired asset
by something happening in the economy
right now how many people want to sell
you commercial real estate at a fair
price right now that is not
impaired they all think it's still worth
what it was worth in january
okay so that you know that's kind of
difficult
so what's my next thing go buy i'm not
so silly as to go
buy like uh 20th century stock go by
apple amazon
facebook you know twitter
oh by the way back in 2012 i wrote the
mobile wave
you know what i said in the mobile wave
i said go buy facebook amazon apple
twitter
it was a good idea in 2012.
if you had done it then you would have
made 10 times your money
very good idea not the same idea
this week right i mean at this point
you know is is apple computer going to
go up by a factor of 10 from here
right maybe it might double it might be
cut in half but you know you're
with the best equity in the world you've
got a you've got equal upside down side
you're really just
yeah there's no asymmetric exactly and
so when you started to look at this
um did you look at real estate precious
metals
and bitcoin or kind of what was what was
the on the menu if you will for
evaluation
i went okay and this is where i got it i
got to give a plug to my friend eric
weiss eric rice
running his own bitcoin bitcoin
investment
you know advisory service you know he's
saying this is what i'm doing and i'm
just dismissing him like
uh whatever this bitcoin thing i don't
know what it is but it's crazy
crypto and it's like shell game so
he just he keeps mentioning it and i
keep thinking about it
and then then one day we're sitting
around my pool in miami
and he starts explaining it and
something clicks in my head
that maybe this is a pretty good idea
you know like
i i have been beaten over the head
with a two by four and so i'm a bit more
open-minded but i start thinking about
it
and then i realized i really gotta look
at precious metal you know you go
now you go to the robert kiyosaki
silver gold or bitcoin you know choose
one
and so we get down to choosing are we
going to invest in precious metals or
bitcoin
am i gonna i already dismissed
commercial real estate i dismissed a
market basket of equities the spider
you know nasdaq 100 that stuff's just
not
compelling i you know i tell you what i
want right
what i want is something that that might
be cut in half that can go up by a
factor of 10.
asymmetric payoff by the way that's what
any intelligent investors
that's what you want when you bought
amazon in 2011
that's what you were getting when you
bought apple computer when the iphone
came out
that's what every every rational winner
is getting
you want a 10x upside and then you want
yeah i can even live with losing all the
money
although here's the catch you know like
every good investment
in my opinion if you're going to put a
lot of money at work the
the winning formula for the past 10
years or 15 years has been
find a digital dominant network
that's dematerialized some some
fundamental thing
the mobile network is apple the
information network at google
the video network youtube you know the
social network facebook
uh even twitter speech network
dematerialize
and amazon the retail network
you buy them when they're a hundred
billion dollar market cap
when something hits a hundred billion
dollar and by when they're ten
times bigger than the next biggest thing
and they're a hundred billion dollars
they're probably going to crush
everything and at that point
like you know i remember lecturing wall
street guys
in 2011 2012 about apple
you know and here's what they said he
said well we know you love apple
and and you think it's going to beat the
world
but you know our idea is if apple goes
up too high we're going to sell the
stock and we're going to buy hp
so we can in dell so we can diversify
your computer portfolio
and then if and if all your tech names
if apple and amazon and facebook go up
too much
we're going to sell those so you don't
get too much in technology
okay and my answer was what you know
if you think about it broadly there's no
example of a successful company in the
history of the world
that wasn't a technology company
standard oil was a technology company
if you go and go to hershey's factory
you'll find they figured out how to
manufacture 50
000 candy bars in a clean room and it's
the most sophisticated piece of
technology
you will ever see in your life you think
they're not technology companies you're
just ignorant
there is no there is no winning
investment in a company that's not a
technology company
at their time general electric there's a
time
when electricity was interesting
technology
boeing same thing before we could fly
so so the idea you sell too much tech is
a foolish idea in my opinion
the idea that you sell apple when it
gets too big is another foolish idea
like well there's never been a company
that was 500 billion in
market cap what or or trillion right
they're people saying that
there's never been a company as valuable
as apple because there's never been a
company
as valuable as apple and another way to
say that is
there's never been a company that could
create a software
camera change the way it works and ship
it to a billion people
overnight for a nickel and if you could
actually ship a product to a billion
people overnight for a nickel
you could create a lot of value with no
cost so
obviously these digital networks
facebook apple
amazon you know you you could see them
they're all around us
they're they're insanely um
value generating but there but there's
another dynamic here which is the
network effect right metcaps law
it's like as soon as as soon as
everybody uses facebook
you know you can't how do i get
257 of my closest friends to switch to
the next thing
it's really hard like twitter
you know how do you get all of your
followers on twitter
to switch to the next speech network you
think
you know even if you know even if a guy
has a massive
following on twitter you think he's
going to switch
you know to another thing probably not
he's going to be the last person to
leave
so you you know you're buried in
concrete there
so now we come back to bitcoin
okay the the number one knock on bitcoin
uh for the outsider is well it's just
software someone else can copy it
and i think bitcoiners they don't do
themselves justice here
i mean sometimes i think the exchanges
and and some of the others they over
promote the fact that there's
237 different crypto pairs you can trade
right and if i've done that it's like
that
it's that long tale where all of a
sudden there's one thing
and i want to have a list of 47 things
but but you know what's an epiphany you
know the epiphany is when you're
a young ceo and you're like i'm going to
put a sales person in every single
state in america there's 50 states 50
sales people there's an epiphany when
you go to new york city
and you realize that half of all the
money in the country is in one city
and then you realize that maybe you're
being captured by orthodoxy
so in this entire crypto area
it's it's great to have all the
innovation and it's good to experiment
with this and that and d5 and maybe
that'll work and maybe they'll work and
maybe that'll work
but to the outsider the outsider you
look at it and you're like well what if
everybody moves their money off of
bitcoin to the to
ether or to whatever or to yoyo coin and
you know and they stop and and
then someone puts this language eight
pages of language
in front of you what happens if there's
a hard fork or a soft fork
you know how debilitating inducing
that would be to get to deliver eight
pages of legal disclaimers on hard fork
soft fork
risk like you mean like my crypto can
float away
and they get all anxiety written so
you've got to get beyond that
okay and but it's easy to get beyond
that the easy way to get beyond it is to
say
look this is a proof of work crypto
network
designed to be a store of value and the
only thing we're gonna do
is maintain a constant store of value as
a digital gold
and we're going to expend huge amounts
of energy
to protect that network and upgrade that
network and
you can take your 500 million dollars
out of the bank and put it on our
network and
everybody in the community is going to
spend every
iota of their energy to make sure no one
f's with that network
okay okay all right so hold on so when
you when you
start to understand this uh it sounds
like you
pretty astutely bitcoin everything else
there was a separation in your mind in
terms of understanding that
uh and as you were learning about that
were you going into this um with an
open mind as uh i don't even remember
that i tweeted this thing you know in
the past
i know i've got this problem this is the
promise of this thing is a store of
value like let me go explore it
or do you basically have people who are
kind of guiding you and pushing you and
saying hey
this is the solution this is your
solution like is this a self-guided tour
or is this out externally guided by i am
completely
oblivious to any previous opinion i had
had
than the before but i i didn't follow
bitcoin all through the 2017
bitcoin cash for any of the fireworks
that were very colorful i missed it all
right
okay so i you know i show up with a
queen slate in 2020
and i'm reading about this is history
and i'm looking at
you know andreas's you know videos and
your videos and dan hell's videos and
i'm reading the bitcoin
standard by safedean and i'm reading
parker lewis's
essays and uh you got indoctrinated by
the bitcoin community
you got hit with all the content yeah
and
and all the maximalists and i'm seeing
max kaiser and i'm you know
and i'm sorry i'm like i'm starting to
figure out there seems to be some
interesting
drama here but it's more entertaining
for me right
and here's the thing that really just
that just kicks you over the edge though
it's just when you go to real
bitcoin dominance and you look at
bitcoin
and then bitcoin cash and then the next
one the next one you're always
okay bitcoin is 92 percent of everything
and the next competitor is two percent
and then the next competitor is 1.5
okay the number one knock on bitcoin is
well maybe it's the myspace to facebook
it's like
absolutely not if you know anything
about myspace you realize that myspace
was never worth more than a billion
dollars
okay myspace was one was 200 times
smaller than bitcoin is right now
it was never that case right there's
never an example of a hundred billion
dollar
monster digital network that was
vanquished once it got to
that dominant position so all you got to
do is see that chart
and then you think about the think about
the dynamic and the network effect and
you're like
this is already one right it's one it's
been tested
and you know and by the way the hard
forks i think are a big advantage
the fact that the fact that bitcoin went
through it
and we saw what happened and we saw that
the community would defend
bitcoin that's what gives
a person like me
to invest hundreds of millions of
dollars in bitcoin i i don't want to
hear
that you've got a new idea and you're
upset over transaction fees and you
would like to
implement smart contracts so you got to
change everything i don't want to hear
that
i want to hear that you're going to
defend the network
to the death against someone that's
going to break it
or compromise it in any way shape or
form
when you decide personally this is a
good idea
uh i'm gonna take a material amount of
the 500 million dollars
and i'm gonna go buy bitcoin with it
you've got
a board you've got shareholders you've
got regulators there's there's
a number of kind of stakeholders right
that people who either have financial
interest in what you're doing
uh or really care about what you're
doing uh from a regulatory standpoint
what are those conversations like do you
just go to the board and say hey
there's this thing called bitcoin i'm
gonna take 250 million dollars i'm gonna
go buy it
do you kind of warm them up with some
information first like what is that
conversation at the board level like
i started signing them homework
and they all know you
so they you know they've all watched a
variety of your podcast
uh they all know andreas
they all they all required to watch the
debate between eric voorhees and peter
schiff on gold
on on fiat versus bitcoin what is better
money
right and then a non-stop stream of
essays
you know on macroeconomics and bitcoin
theory and you know you know the who's
who litany of people you've interviewed
when alden publishes her piece it goes
to my board you know
the bullish case for bitcoin goes to the
board
all of those things and and it's and
between them and the general counsel and
the cfo
and myself we're all basically just
going down the rabbit hole
and following that is this you know is a
series of discussions
one-on-ones with everybody everybody
goes off
does their own homework we all come
together
lots of group discussion we all split
the cfo goes off to to to
uh to organize and start to consult with
arrays of accountants
the general counsel goes off to consult
with a raise of attorneys
you know then we go off and consult with
a raise of financial advisors then we
consult with arrays of bankers
then we come back together again and
then we share then we have deliberations
then we deliberate some more and then we
think very carefully
about what is the appropriate and
prudent way
in order to begin to move forward
with or affect the strategy here all
right so the first purchase
uh is 250 million dollars um you
announced today that you did
uh another 175 million so you're now at
425 million dollars which is uh
almost all of that 500 million dollars
of cash or a good portion of it
walk us through i got a ton of questions
around what i'll call
operationally investing hundreds of
millions of dollars so
how do you think about entering the
market and trying not to move
price how do you think about uh otc
right uh desks um obviously for those
who are listening who
might be confused michael and the team
is not going on coinbase and letting a
400 million dollar you know market order
rip
so there's some very thoughtful things
that go into this let's talk first just
about how do you actually acquire
this much bitcoin uh without kind of
moving price
and before we get there i'll make one
more point we had 500 million
in cash we wanted to buy our own stock
back
with it or put it into some some asset
like bitcoin
our first step is to announce that we're
thinking that through our second step is
announce a tinder offer for our stock
250 million that took place the same day
we announced that we bought the 250
million in bitcoin
then we have a 20-day period where we
wait
for our shareholders to decide if
they're going to tinder and how much
so we had to move through that when we
got done we actually
bought 60 million dollars worth of our
stock that hit the wire
in the last few days too so what we've
our real goal
was to invest it all so that was the
it was going to be so it was 250 in
bitcoin the tender ends up being 60
million or so you're at like 310
and then that hat you had kind of
another 175 million that you could play
with and still keep some cash in the
bank
yeah and it's the shareholders decision
as to how much of that will be
tender right so we we wait for them and
then after the tender offer we had
excess cash in our treasury so
the next step is for us to is to invest
our treasury cash
so that's what we announced today in
fact we've wrapped it all up so
substantially 95 of that money
is either invested in our stock or in
bitcoin and we've accomplished that
in short order right like over the
course of six weeks or four weeks
now uh regarding acquiring that much
bitcoin
first of all i can't give you
like exact blow-by-blow details because
i've got security issues
and the world is watching and i
i can't but what i can do is
is is i can describe to you
if you were running a company how you
should think about this
you know if you were in my position
which is you're gonna go
and you're on you're going to audition a
bunch of
uh a bunch of uh institutional grade
exchanges you're going to work through
and look for
institutional grade custodians
yeah yeah you're going to look at you
know all
all of the security issues all the
technology issues etc
you're gonna you're gonna think about
the team
you're gonna build a relationship with
them and then
you're gonna buy if you're gonna buy
that much
you're going to buy it in
thousands or tens of thousands or 100
000 plus
small transactions day and night
minute by minute over there like over
the course of many many many days so
so it's not like we're going in i
i'll sit and i'll watch this happening
and i've got a great team
you know a great team that i've worked
with and some excellent professionals
they are brilliant geniuses at what they
do
but let me tell you they've got great
technology too
right it's like and you got to have the
right technology
you got to have the right team and then
you have to be very patient
like very very patient you know like
i'll watch people walk in on monday
morning and you know i was like okay
some dude
just got up at 9am and decided to buy
some bitcoin and the price
spikes you know whenever i see that i'm
like
well that guy won't be in the market
very long
because no one that really wanted to buy
a lot of bitcoin
would be so silly as to spike
the price so hard you know i i can tell
you
this which is we bought 425 million
dollars worth of it and
we never ran the price not a dollar
like you don't know impressive yeah it's
pretty impressive if i'm in the market
you wouldn't know
that i'm trading against you ever
because
that's just that's not how you get stuff
done right let the market come to you
so the good news is if you want to buy
hundreds of millions or sell hundreds of
millions you can do it
and not be seen and and you can do it
without moving the market materially or
panicking anybody
but you have to have the right team the
right tools and the right discipline you
can't be in a hurry
got it that makes sense how has the
reaction been from
other ceos or people who kind of are
outside the company
i'm assuming that you've gotten um
people coming inbound that are peers
are they laughing at you are they
excited are they asking how did you do
this why did you do this like what are
those conversations like
well first of all i think this is a year
where every ceo
is busy like minding his own business
right like that that they've either got
a business that that
that has serious serious solvency
issues or or struggle or they've got a
business that's being digitally
disrupted or twisted
one way or the other and or they've got
all sorts of
of employee care and feeding issues
so this is not the year where a lot of
ceos are necessarily sitting around
shooting the whatever about you know
what's happening this year
right everybody's kind of all hands on
deck
working hard the people i do speak to
though
and i speak to some i would say
everybody has uh
has had a lot of their assumptions
shaken this year
assumptions about you know how the
market will behave
assumptions about regulations right i
mean assumptions about
international business assumptions about
their balance sheet
and things that were inconceivable last
year
right oracle tick tock
you know all sorts of interesting things
that you
you will see on the paper and people are
just like nod and like not even a second
thought like oh yeah
that's happening that's happening all
those things
are are are being considered this year
to a much greater degree
so i i do have people coming to me and
and and they want to know
how do we think about it and why do we
do it and
you know and and they're all starting to
look to think what's their angle on this
now
and so i think it's catalyzing people
to be much more open-minded
yeah i think that makes a lot of sense
do you feel like uh
you've kind of broken the damn open and
now a bunch of
people will follow or do you think that
this is kind of uh slowly but surely it
will take a lot of time for more to kind
of follow in your footsteps
i i think it's like the four minute mile
i think the people told himself they
couldn't do it and then someone does it
and then
in the next year dozens and dozens of
people do it
right um this particular case
uh there's a lot of stuff that
i've done in my career that was a lot
harder than this
and i and i will say any entrepreneur
that ever successfully
launches a business and you know and
gets to profitability
we'll have accomplished something much
harder than what we did so
it's a it's a uh it's a challenging
project but it's not beyond
um beyond the capability of any any uh
management team
i think that a lot of people just kind
of had a mental block
uh you know or they it's just in this
block of i just dismiss it
i don't even consider it and then they
get focused on something else
my own experience is you know on the day
from the day that i decided
that i wanted to buy bitcoin if if i
decided on that day
as an individual you go to these you
know high-end exchanges it's gonna be
six weeks
to get through the kyc for an individual
if you want to do it if you're a company
a private company
and if you had your team all around you
from the point that
that you thought it was interesting
you're 12
weeks to 18 weeks to get through the
hoops
if you're a nimble publicly traded
company i think you're looking at six
months
and if you're a good company like just a
good rational publicly
company put on the docket you would do
it in nine to 12 months
and so i i think that um
people were kind of oblivious to the
to the the need slash the role of
bitcoin and the bitcoin narrative
of digital gold right this is the
ultimate
inflation hedge this is this is if it's
it's not 10x better than gold
it's 100x maybe it's a thousand
expedition
we could go on for hours i could tell
you why i think it's a thousand x better
than gold
but let's just assume since we're
preaching to the choir that
it's a thousand x better than gold once
you realize that it's 1000x better than
gold
from that point it's
minimum 12 weeks if you went
like a bat out of hell and probably six
months
and i kind of feel that if people were
waiting to see
if this was possible well they kind of
saw our announcement august
so the six-month clock starts in august
if if they were uh super
if they were just perfectly configured
if they had all the same characteristics
as us
then they start focusing on this in may
or june nobody's thinking about this in
march or april i was just so busy
trying to keep the doors open and and
their bells getting wrong
so take august and say august september
october
i you know december january february i
think that what you're going to see
is over the next two three four months
something interesting
and um you know
the the other point right that's not not
lost upon me is
there's 3 500 publicly traded companies
there's five trillion
dollars in their treasuries and it's all
melting
and and yeah at some point you have a
fiduciary obligation to not lose the
money
okay yeah like it's
it used well it used to be acceptable to
be conservative but that was before the
asset inflation rate went from six
percent to 30
you know when the inflation rate goes to
30 percent it's not necessarily
something you can ignore
so i think that a lot of people are
getting catalyzed right now
i think i think it has to be kind of ceo
cfo led
right because it is an innovative thing
but i think that uh that we've shown
people
how to do it you know and and we've
shown them that it's
it's possible and straightforward and
and once it's like anything
if i tell you it's possible go figure it
out on the internet or go through it on
youtube you can figure it out yourself
right all you got to know is that it's
possible you know it's possible to run
52 miles in a single day go figure it
out you're going to go google 52 miles
in a single day and then all of a sudden
fall down the rabbit hole so i think
people now know it's possible but i i
don't think
you can expect them to move in less than
six months reasonably in
a year how are you thinking about and
last question before we get to the rapid
fire how are you thinking about the
volatility
right so obviously uh it's one of the
most volatile assets
that you could have chosen um and when
we talk about volatility it's not like
hey may go up two or two percent or down
two percent you can have double digit
percentage days
uh up or down um does that change your
strategy
is this just your long term holding it
for you know
years and years kind of how do you think
about that well so first of all
i think the volatility is falling and i
i
think all you gotta do is look at the
chart and i there's a narrative like
everybody's like everybody wants to say
that they know something about crypto
wants to jump up and say well you know
it's volatile
well well it was volatile in 2017 you
know
when like individuals are trading it on
their mobile phone
but yeah think about what i just what i
just said about how we acquired it
we buy 175 million dollars
i'm in the market every minute of the
day
for multiple days in a row i'm damping
the volatility
one person like me right
in every every trading day that i'm in
the market i'm damping it to the upside
and the downside and i'm damping it with
large sums of money
right and and so how many of how many
institutions does it take before they
damp it
right like i'm the i'm the dude i'm like
okay i'll pay an extra whatever but stop
this thing
i'm holding it for a hundred freaking
years right it's like i'm not really
i'm not the day trader guy that's
worried about it so
i think that as the institutions come in
and as they buy bigger amounts
they're damping the volatility that's my
first observation my second observation
is
crypto trades 168 hours a week
every other asset trades 35 a week at
best and sometimes less on holidays
right
you're trading i i look at this thing in
awe
you know when i look at these exchanges
saturday night
9 30 p.m and i'm watching
the things stream and i'm like this is
the most
magical hardest working security in the
history of the world
and and i would think everybody ought to
be in awe
that the thing's not going haywire it's
remarkably
non-volatile in that regard like
in my opinion you could go and you could
go into the market
and you could liquidate 50 or 100
million dollars worth of this stuff
in a matter of an hour any hour of the
day any
day of the week on a holiday and maybe
you take a three percent haircut
but go try to liquidate 100 million
dollars of gold on a saturday afternoon
in istanbul on the street side
you know so by so that my answer is i
don't think it's that volatile but my
other answer
beyond this let's be honest there's a
negative real yield on
everything else i can buy okay
gold's got a negative three four five
percent real yield
in my opinion we talked about why bonds
have a negative real yield
it's just a question we're just going to
debate is it a
seven percent asset inflation or fifteen
percent or three percent
but it doesn't really matter every other
non-volatile asset
is a negative real yield which means
that everything else is
lifeblood draining out of my veins so if
my choice would be to accept some
volatility
and live or i had non-volatile cash
that bought 30 percent less in a matter
of eight weeks
non-volatile that was 30 percent less at
that rate
you're not going to make it through the
decade and so
volatility is just something you got to
live with but i
but i really think that there's there's
there's a group of crypto enthusiasts
that lived the last 10 years
and and they are the result of their
experience they lived through
a difficult time and they're heroes and
i respect them
but you live through that you look
through volatility i think the next 10
years are not going to look like that
i think the next 10 years is you have
people coming in that are that are
moving hundreds of millions of dollars
in and out of the market they're going
to tend to damp all the volatility and
and and the institutions are going to
dampen because in their interest
and so if there is any it's just going
to be to the upside
for the good of everybody and otherwise
not a big problem for me
i literally think that is the perfect
way to look at this
is uh what is it 200 billion dollar
asset today
uh market cap wise go to eight nine
trillion you're looking at 40 plus x
right the gold market cap and uh you're
talking about an asset that is superior
uh in almost every single way and so if
you think it's just going to be equal on
a market cap basis
uh you're not a student of history uh
because we know that they usually tend
to
uh have much larger market caps and so
when you start to look at just the
numbers
right you can not only put big numbers
to work in the market
but also the upside of this thing is
incredible uh over a long enough time
period
it's not crazy gold is a great narrative
but
to say that this is much better than
gold undersells it
because the truth is if you look at
these treasuries there's something like
200
trillion dollars worth of debt
instruments
and other treasury instruments that have
a negative real yield
and and precious metal is just one of
them so if you're looking at 10 trillion
dollars in gold there's easily a hundred
trillion dollars of
you know what is the shadow money 75
trillion of that 75 trillion of
sovereign debt
50 trillion of other stuff so you're
really looking at 200
trillion or more of negative real yield
the only debate is how negative it is
and bitcoin is the only thing i could
find is positive
you know i could find a thing we'd be
talking about it
no-brainer i asked the same two
questions to everybody to
finish up what is the most important
book you've ever read
okay you're gonna hate me for this but
it's the moon is a harsh mistress
okay and uh you know robert heinlein was
my favorite author growing up
i'm a rocket scientist and
of course it's it's uh
it's about a protagonist computer whose
name is mike
who saves the moon
so i like that a lot and i like and i
grew up with that it was very
inspirational
so speaking of the moon aliens believer
or non-believer
i think they're out there i think that i
think that there's
so many stars and galaxies and planets
statistically it just seems to be
impossible that
somewhere there isn't somebody
i uh i tend to agree with you the galaxy
is very very big
uh you get asked me one question to uh
to finish up what's the one question you
got for me
jack dorsey has a one word
twitter bio and that one word is bitcoin
and he's also got 10 billion dollars in
cash and cash equivalents between
twitter and square
and to my knowledge none of it is
invested in bitcoin either square
or twitter you want to help me try to
persuade
jack to like you know break off a small
500 million or billion dollars and go
buy some bitcoin because
i know he loves the community and i know
he's doing
as much as he can to help but the single
most useful thing he could do to help is
lead on the corporate
treasury side if he bought a billion
dollars worth of bitcoin what do you
think happens the next day
uh i think that he's thought about it uh
would be my guess
uh my guess is that there are uh bigger
problems that he uh perceives uh in
terms of activist investors and kind of
you know he's he's always the um i joke
and say uh
show me another uh entrepreneur who's
built
two tens of billions of dollar market
cap companies
and is running them simultaneously and
uh yet somehow people still have a
problem with the guy
which is insane to me i don't he's an
amazing guy
and he's inspirational but it's not like
he shirks controversy
oh no no look i i absolutely think that
uh
i again this is me speaking my opinion
obviously i've never talked to jack
about this i don't have any inside
information
uh i would guess that if it was his
choice
he would absolutely do it if he kind of
had sole power uh
i think that um you know
you kind of pick your battles sometimes
and my guess is that uh
when elliott uh management is uh
knocking on the door and basically got a
target on your back as the ceo
the first thing you don't want to
propose in the board meeting is uh hey
why don't we take 500 million dollars
and go buy bitcoin
but at the same time doesn't mean that
that wouldn't be the right thing to go
do
just you got to pick your battle
sometimes if we can get the crypto
community to give them some air cover
or go wage a a a charm offensive
what we need is we need uh the bitcoin
community to go like meme elliott
management to death
and then uh they'll back off maybe and
leave them alone so i don't know
well we'll see look it's um i tend to
think that there will be many more
people who will follow this
i think you're right in terms it'll just
take a little bit of time for them to
kind of get geared up and do it
uh i don't know if people will do as
much as you guys did on a percentage
basis kind of out of the gate right it
feels like maybe people start with
five ten percent just because humans are
naturally
just um they lack conviction they want
to be conservative they kind of feel
like they're being prudent you know
whatever
i tend to think actually the argument
you laid out is
not only uh conservative because you're
actually protecting the cash uh but it's
also very prudent in the sense of kind
of how you did
you know 50 into bitcoin 50 as a tender
and then kind of doubled up or you know
kind of filled up
uh with the rest in bitcoin uh and so
we'll see what happens but
um you know if if no one has said it to
you yet
uh just we're cheering you on so keep
going because uh
it's pretty incredible that uh that you
did this and uh
i um i said it when uh when you first
put out the very first press release you
guys bought the original bitcoin
purchase
um i said to multiple people i said look
this isn't somebody who doesn't
understand what they're doing
right it was very clear in the language
you used in the press release etc
uh this is a bitcoiner who is running
this company
uh and very much understands the macro
environment uh kind of their their asset
choices if you will
uh and has chosen bitcoin for i think
all of the reasons that uh the bitcoin
community is attracted to it
um and so that you know for whatever
reason came through pretty
clearly to me in that uh in that press
release so uh so it's cool to see
yeah well like i guess i would end just
by saying that
that uh i find the entire bitcoin
community to be inspirational
and i did note in our press release one
of one of the key drivers
of our belief in the success of this is
the community ethos
it's a it's a pretty amazing group of
people and
uh and all of the thinking and all of
the initiatives i just find to be
extraordinary and i think i think that
we wouldn't be doing
what we're doing without everybody
that's ever passed through this podcast
that means a lot how can people find you
on the internet or find out more about
microstrategy
um microstrategy is microstrategy.com
i'm michael underscore sailor at twitter
you can probably google me and you'll
get every single one of my
contacts if you want awesome
listen michael thank you so much for
doing this this was fantastic and
we will absolutely do this again at some
point in the future well thanks for
having me